foreign
[Music]
exciting front row access this week it's
been more than a decade since James
Cameron's Avatar shattered box office
records and to this day it Remains the
highest grossing title globally but now
the moment we've all been waiting for
the sequel Avatar the way of water opens
this
weekend's supposed to fight
protect the people
Avatar the way of water tells the story
of the solely family the trouble that
follows them and the lengths that they
go to keep each other safe the soles
find themselves leaving the forest for
the water this time here's what director
James Cameron had to say about taking on
a new element in this film
we had to figure out how to do water you
know movies called the way of water but
we had to figure out the way of water
for performance capture and for CG make
it absolutely seamless which I think we
we accomplished and that's part of the
The dreamlike Wonder of the of the movie
which is part of our stock and trade you
know doing Avatar if you will
and a lot of the water scenes were
actually filmed underwater so newcomer
to the Pandora World Kate Winslet shares
what that was like so the underwater
performance capture um
it's it's a it's a first of all it's a
huge amount to think about so there's
not just the physical challenge of
holding your breath there's then the
added challenge of acting out a scene
underwater where everything is very
different you're having to imagine coral
reefs you're having to picture you know
other not the mechaina swimming around
you
um and often acting with a child who is
an actual fact a safety diver who's 35
years old and not a nine-year-old girl
um so there's there's that sort of added
element too then you have the challenge
of your movements are very very
different underwater so rather than sort
of sculling all the time or desperately
trying to kick your legs to sort of stay
in one place finding that Serenity and
that calm that's another thing so
there's all of that to take care of
first then you have a wetsuit with
motion capture bubbles all over you then
you have a helmet and an arm with a
GoPro sat in the front of it
well Kate Winslet joins the returning
cast of Sam Worthington Zoe saldano
Sigourney Weaver and many others with
some other new and upcoming newcomers as
well and I had the chance to screen the
movie last night don't worry no spoilers
and before I say anything else if
there's one thing you take away from
what I'm about to tell you is that I
highly recommend seeing it in 3D it was
unlike anything I've ever seen before
the movie is offered in 2D of 3D isn't
your thing but I'm telling you you will
truly feel like you are underwater and
from credit to credit the movie is about
3 hours and 20 minutes so be sure to
give yourself enough time and plan out
those bathroom breaks strategically but
all I will say is that it truly lived up
to the hype after all these years and
that's a big shoe to fill but they did
it highly recommend it Avatar the way
water officially opens in theaters
Friday be sure to check it out and let
me know what you think